(audience cheer and applaud)
- Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome
one of my favorite females, Vanessa Bayer!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- I'm so excited to be here!
- My God, I know, (Drew's mic muffles)
This whole thing is gonna blow up.
And yet I never follow
my script, so forget it.
Oh my God, I...
I'm so excited.
- I'm so excited.
- I just love so many of
the amazing characters
that you created on "Saturday Night Live",
I quote you every day of my life.
What was one character that
rises to the top for you,
or that still resonates every
day or that you're like,
"Ah, I just need to be
that person right now"?
- I think the person,
the character that is the
most truly me at my core,
is The Bar Mitzvah Boy, because,
(audience cheers and applauds)
- He's the cutest.
I mean, it must feel so good,
'cause you would just move
your mouth in a certain smile
and the whole room would
like go roaring laughter,
that must feel really good.
- It was, it was really fun.
I mean it took a few tries.
I've tried subtle stuff like that before
and it didn't always,
sometimes the audiences would be like,
"No, thank you". (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Oh I know those
crickets and tumbleweeds.
You're like, (vocalizes comedy flourish)
and they're just like, "No".
- Not for us.
- And you're like comedy is,
the drive home is painful
and awkward and vulnerable.
- Yes. Yes.
- Okay, so this amazing
show, "I Love That For You"
is living out a dream job.
It's like a shopping network.
- Yes. Yes.
- And I'm just curious,
if you weren't a famous
comedian or doing this show,
what job would you pick as a dream job?
- I actually think that would be it,
because I watched a lot of
home shopping when I was a kid
and I really loved how they talked,
and how they talked about the products
and touched the products.
And I also, I think because
I watched it so much
at such a young age,
it's like a language I learned. (laughs)
- Does it ever get actually
stuck in your head?
Like a flight pattern for performance?
Like I couldn't watch Samantha
in "Sex and the City", ironically,
because every line
I started delivering and talked like that.
- (laughs) Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well honey, did that
ever affect you that way?
- Yes, exactly, exactly.
- But okay, this is an odd
dovetail, but you know.
Love life.
I'm just going straight in.
- Oh yes, okay.
- Tell me about your love life.
Is it true that you're on a dating app?
- Yes, I think I'm, I think
we might be on the same.
- [Drew] I think we are.
- Have you ever seen
more DJs in your life?
(audience laughs)
- Also, I'm pretty sure
that you have to be a
surfing photographer.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And you have to have someone else's kid-
- Yeah.
- In your pictures.
- To show you're the uncle type.
- Yes, exactly.
But you have to have a
huge dog, that's so scary,
in a way that's like, "Who is that for?"
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- And you have to be a foodie.
- Yeah.
- And shirtless.
- You have to be shir,
the shirtless photos are so, and there's,
it's just like, yeah.
Who, who is...?
It's, it's a real, it's a tough,
it's a tough place to be.
First of all, I don't know
if you experienced this too,
but a lot of times I'll match with someone
and then they'll never message me.
- Oh my God.
- And I'm like...
- Wait, raise of hands.
Who has had this happen
to them on a dating app?
- Right?
I'm like, why are you here?
- Is it just like a feather in the cap
and then they move on?
- That's what I'm also, like
why don't they feel?
Don't they have better
stuff to do with their time
than match with someone
and be like, "Okay"
and then like, go on?
(audience laughs)
Use that moment to write a book, or...
- There's a cafe in Japan
that's about that for writers.
- Yes!
(audience applauds)
Go there.
(bright theme music)